you had a nose job no I didn't have a
nose job dude I'll take one if you want
to put money in like a GoFundMe for a
nose yeah it's so crazy if I'd actually
be too weird
but I couldn't breathe that night when I
would go to sleep at night my nose I
couldn't breathe less and less you were
one of those strips like an [ __ ]
oh I'd wear three of them they don't
work they worked for me daily oh well
I'd [ __ ] feel like I was coming some
justcome was just building up and
they're just puddling up in the back of
my head so you use those a night open up
your Airways yeah I can feel how good it
feels right now with those things on
because you got to do three though you
got to have one on the regular and you
got to have two at the slaw not build a
bridge oh dude you got a you got to have
a friend of Georgia Tech to help you out
you've got to have a blueprint you got
to go on plan do it right oh and some in
the Deep Web there's different ways you
can really get your breath breathing
really just open yet well you would you
have a deviated septum no I just had
some [ __ ] who knows man you know I
don't know what happened the man said I
could've got hit by something I remember
somebody threw something at me once but
it knocked me out on him and what it was
damn and I remember what else happened
dude fell into something that was made
out of cement one time a great I had
stone we're jumping on different
headstones at the graveyard when I was
young
[ __ ] took one of the dome dude that
might do it yeah it took a
seventy-year-old right to the doorway
and what else happened but I don't know
but I felt like the devil was trying to
choke me out at night because it would
get less and worse nothing worse and so
he said you did or didn't have surgery
so I went in and they put you under I
thought you're just gonna stop in now
you can't just stop in a fix the nose
and I'm like yeah you need nose too yeah
and they went in they went in there you
know when that man got in there and I
was asleep you know which I think's a
little [ __ ] up I'd rather be awake and
see who is in there you don't want to be
away from that's it
I don't want to be him you know know
these people it's true sweaty you don't
know get inside your body while you're
asleep dude it's illegal its assault
brother yeah yeah so when I was worried
about was uh you know just what would
happen and I went in there and he said
it was a mess when they get in there and
they like shaved down like parts that
are way up in here in the top you don't
see anything
you couldn't notice it but he said there
was a lot of scar tissue in here that
they could cut and like and like and
just stuff like that but I can how long
ago was that dude I blew a [ __ ]
batwing out of one of my nose as one
morning dude it was a booger that
honestly way after the surgery Oh a gold
miner with turned it in for cash brother
this thing was huge gelatinous yes it
looked like an embryo for so after the
surgery yeah dude I had no surgeon yet
to put brackets in my nose really then
that do you stitches to keep the
brackets in yeah cuz I shattered my nose
all sorts of places from a fight from a
fight I was the worst the worst so I'm
on painkillers get an addiction
addicting painkillers after the nose
surgery but then they went in I had
these back to my nose for weeks and
weeks and weeks then I come here I take
him out and I'm so scared for them take
him out and they they just snip the
stitches and pull it in like this thing
like this big comes out and it felt so
glorious oh oh it felt nice yeah like a
candle coming out like a big old candle
how to make it spray out there's glory
it's kind of wild over different ways
you could really come if people really
could master the use of different canals
in their body agree you know like that
was damn near close to the sex organs
dude I took a big dump on ecstasy one
time it almost came I've see I've heard
that before though and that's pretty
wild you know it's a little scary did
you make you feel a little homoerotic
like you can feel the squirrels run a
little no no but do you mean yeah it
makes you feel you know like you like
men might be trying to get to know you
yeah right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh good what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]